on peut dire presque sans exagérer que
les jours de certaines populations de
caribous sont comptés au québec des
hardes isolé de caribous montagnard et
forestier perturbé par les activités
forestières sont au seuil de
l'extinction et selon des spécialistes
il faudra plus que des enclos de
protection pour espérer les sauver
[Musique]
c'est carré bleu sont aujourd'hui dans
des situations tellement précaire contre
un des moyens qui dépassent l'imaginaire
des gens pour essayer de les sombres
ya aucun plein de retours en nature donc
ces enclos sont peut-être des mots voire
à caribou
on ne prie aussi ce qui se fait à
d'autres endroits à travers le monde
pour protéger
à court terme ces espèces là pour
s'orienter pu dire qu'est ce qu'on fait
on est face à un problème où on a de
moins en moins d'1
[Musique]
dans le penser à nos aînés nous disaient
qu'ils avaient beaucoup de carbo avant
adrian jérôme est la chef de la nation
anishnabe du lac-simon près de val-d'or
[Musique]
je savais que les coupes forestières qu'
il ya eu le déclin du cargo
wallace et les caribous disparaît
ici l'habitat du caribou couvrait au
moins trois territoires ancestraux
plusieurs décennies d'exploitation
minière et forestière ont contribué à
morceler sinon détruire l'air de survie
du cervidé
aujourd'hui l'art de val d'or ne compte
plus que cet individu
en mars 2020 le ministère des forêts de
la faune et des parcs les amis en enclos
pour les protéger des prédateurs comme
l'ours et le loup qui sont plus en plus
avantagée par les centaines de
kilomètres de chemins forestiers
ça fait plusieurs années encore lequel
est différente communauté anishinabe
sont impliqués
dans le dossier du caribou on a rarement
un pouvoir une influence sur la façon
dont ça se passe la biologiste de
geneviève tremblay avait bien accueilli
l'idée du ministère de maître en enclos
la harde de val d'or une mesure
présentée alors comme temporaire on n'a
aucune idée sur le long terme à quoi ça
sert finalement cet enclos
ça fait maintenant deux ans que les
survivants du troupeau de val-d'or
vivent en captivité dans un espace
naturel d'environ 5 hectares
ce jeune faon aînés en confinement c'est
en deux a eu une défense là on peut
pourvoir sur une population avec un
gardien nourrit chaque jour les bêtes en
enclos et des clôtures électrifiées
recouverte de géotextile assurent leur
intimité et ça devrait aider ceux qui
arriveraient à rester un petit peu plus
sauvage ceci étant dit quand on évolue
dans un enclos il ya jamais de prédation
le jour où on sortira de l'on risque
d'être un peu plus neuf et peut-être
plus sujet à la prédation c'est une
stratégie qui est vraiment l'hôte de
dernier recours
sept experts en écologie animal est
catégorique on doit rétablir au plus
vite l'habitat naturel du caribou si on
veut vraiment le sauve est d'offrir aux
animaux qu'on lâche un habitat de
qualité ça signifie maintenir des
massifs de forêt peut perturber de
forêts intactes 9 de vieilles forêts la
même ressource que le caribou et
l'industrie forestière recherche et
malgré la situation critique du caribou
dans certains secteurs le ministère
autorise encore des coupes forestières
au coeur de son habitat naturel
si on est très encore connectés avec la
nature c'est l'écart et bouc qui a fait
partie qui nous a sauvé la vie qui a
sauvé la vie de nos anciens si on cédera
pas le caribou pour un industrie
si on fait des intros puis on continue
la coupe on s'éloigne de la solution
ultime on devrait avoir un plan pour les
réintroduire ce plan manquent pour
l'instant
ce plan c'est la stratégie de protection
du caribou que devait présenter l'an
dernier le gouvernement du québec
le ministère des forêts faune et parcs a
repoussé d'au moins un an le dépôt de sa
stratégie pour une mise en oeuvre
probable en 2024 on parle d'un ministère
ou est-ce qu'on s'occupe à la fois des
forêts où on veut extraire de la forêt
pour créer de la richesse mais aussi de
la faune et des parcs le ministère se
défend bien d'avoir abandonné le caribou
en indiquant que certains secteurs ont
été protégés des coupes forestières la
trappe de prédateur a aussi été
intensifiés et quelques chemins
forestiers démanteler
ces populations alors qu'ils sont
actuellement sur les marges de
l'extinction
si on pense aux ministres dufour
présentement il ya moins de marge de
manoeuvre pour réussir à rétablir la
situation que ne l'avaient ses
prédécesseurs
prenons le cas de l'art de val d'or
quand je parle avec certains groupes qui
ne parlent que de protection du caribou
puis de laisser gambader dans la nature
naturel le territoire qu'on me demande
d'intervenir c'est 25 fois l'île de
montréal c'est du témiscamingue gavalda
c'est c'est comme si on fait plus rien
parce qu'on protège interconnectivité
pour 6,7 caribou qui sont leurs
présentement
mais ce qu'on observe sur le terrain
c'est un déclin généralisé des
populations de caribous dans la quasi
totalité de leur aire de répartition
ils étaient plus de 2 millions 300 mille
dans la promesse dans les années 90
aujourd'hui on en compte environ 200
milles la grande majorité au nord de la
province de chaque côté de la baie
d'ungava
mais quel goût migrateurs au nord subit
des décrets marqué au cours des
dernières décennies parfois allant
jusqu'à 99 % dans l'abondance
un autre groupe le caribou montagnards
vie dans les monts tonnes date des deux
côtés de la frontière entre le québec et
le labrador
aussi un petit troupeau de montagnards
subsistent sur les hauts plateaux des
monts chic chocs en gaspésie derniers
vestiges de cette ligne et au sud du
saint laurent
quant au caribou forestier le plus
commun près des régions habitées il
occupe une bande de forêt boréale situé
entre les 49e et 55e parallèle on en
compte maintenant autour de 6000
tout petit troupeau survivre encore au
sud celui de val d'or et un autre dans
charlevoix
et c'est justement le sort de ces
populations du sud les caribous
forestiers et montagnards qui
préoccupent les experts ces deux groupes
sont pourtant désignés comme espèces
menacées au québec le montagnard de la
gaspésie est même reconnu en voie de
disparition par la loi fédérale sur les
espèces en péril
[Musique]
j'étais biologiste au ministère d'afone
pendant 27 ans le biologiste serge
couturier étudie le caribou et son
habitat depuis quatre décennies la faune
a toujours été le parent pauvre de deux
gros ministères comme les mystères des
forêts actuelle il s'intéresse
particulièrement aux populations isolées
et au seuil de leur disparition on
disait parce qu'ils sont plus en contact
avec l'air de distribution continue du
caribou forestier plus au nord on l'a
rencontré dans le parc des grands
jardins ou le ministère de la faune a
fait construire un autre enclos au coût
de 2 millions 600 mille dollars pour
accueillir les quelques survivants de la
harde isolé de charlevoix il ya eu
val-d'or et maintenance et charlevoix il
ya un dangereux précédent qui est en
train de s'établir s'est un peu retirée
une espèce qui dérange entre guillemets
l'industrie forestière
vu de l'extérieur c'est ce que ça donne
comme impressions ici dans charlevoix
près de 90% de l'habitat du caribou
forestier est perturbé en grande partie
par l'exploitation forestière
au fil des décennies les perturbations
humaines ont contribué à repousser la
limite sud de l'habitat des caribous
forestiers et montagnards en laissant
derrière des pochettes d'individus qui
subsistent à certaines occasions il ya
des groupes de caribou qui reste vivant
attachés à des massifs de forêt protégée
c'est ce qui est arrivé à val d'or où il
ne reste que sept caribou dans
charlevoix ils sont un peu plus d'une
quinzaine et en gaspésie 32 subsiste
encore
particulièrement le carré vous la
gaspésie qui est passé plusieurs
milliers d'individus à 150 ha de cela à
moins de 40 individus aujourd'hui ici
pochette là ces populations isolées sont
en train de disparaître les unes après
les autres mais pourquoi protéger à tout
prix ses bêtes qui sont sur le point de
disparaître
c'est des peines et des ressources
fauniques très importante pour le québec
c'est toujours été là derrière le carré
brusque h des dizaines d'espèces qui ont
eux aussi besoin devient forêt mais en
plus de ça le caribou c'est un canari
dans la mine si on regarde noire des
zones et de charlevoix vador gaspésie
c'est ce qui nous guette dans quinze ou
vingt ans pour d'autres populations de
caribous
pourtant les solutions pour protéger ou
rétablir ces populations elles existent
déjà nous disent les biologistes
ça s'est déjà fait notamment ici à
charlevoix c'est qu'on pourrait placer
ces animaux-là en élevage dans un enclos
comme celui là qui est une
infrastructure qui est bien construite
qui est vraiment impressionnante mais
avoir un plan pour retourner en nature
la progéniture les jeunes issus de cet
élevage en gaspésie on a des styles créé
des intros de maternité zhang ils sont
protégés d'urs à la mise bord pour après
s'en être remis en nature c'est une
stratégie qui est scientifiquement
établi mais qui n'est pas nécessairement
garant de succès si on libère ces
individus là dans un habitat où on n'a
pas endigué les causes du déclin qui
faisait moore et le caribou avant
pour justifier les délais actuels le
ministère a annoncé la création d'une
commission indépendante qui tiendra des
audiences publiques pour évaluer deux
scénarios de gestion de l'habitat du
caribou dont temps qui implique de
sacrifier les arts d'isoler de val-d'or
de charlevoix et de notre troupeau en
déclin dans le secteur pipe - cannes à
l'ouest de baie comeau n'y a aucun
spécialiste du caribou qui est sûre
cette commission là c'est que des
ingénieurs forêt c'est des gens qui sont
reliés industrie forestière deux
communautés autochtones celle des six
pitt sur la côte nord et de masses
taille h au lac saint jean ont déposé un
recours judiciaire pour se faire
entendre par québec
ici à lac-simon près de val-d'or on y
pense sérieusement
parce que
jamais on va céder lesquin bojan mais on
va céder le terrain courant
la majorité de nos travaux de recherche
montre que ça sera pas à cause des
changements climatiques quelques années
vouées à disparaître ou à disparaître
dans les 30 ou 50 prochaines années si
on continue à exploiter la forêt tel
qu'on le présente
[Musique]